you know I'm a fan of what you do but
how did you get into this so the name on
social media stands for MD motivator
which means medical doctor motivator cuz
during the co co in the pandemic I was
in medical school in Sydney Australia
yeah and when I say the pandemic a lot
of people really lacked connection and
felt alone and during that time I had
a uh combination of things that happened
to me I went through a six-year
relationship breakup medical school was
challenging I had ACL surgery there
wasn't anything particular he didn't get
a break but it was just a Breaking Point
and it was finally a Time my life where
I saw a blank slate who am I what's my
purpose what makes me happy and I just
didn't feel I was really in a hole and I
had no one to turn to so I started
making videos to find a friend to create
connection yeah and that's how this
journey started I started making
blindfolded hugging videos where I would
hug strangers because one night when I
was in Sydney Australia in medical
school in the middle of the night I went
for a walk I didn't want to tell my
roommate what I was going through and I
sat there in the rain and these two
women in their late 30s that came up to
me and they're like what's going on and
I was like hysterically crying at the
time and I said nothing and they just
sat there in the wet cement and they
listened to me and the power of just
having a stranger hear me made me want
to do that for others so that's why I
started blindfolding hugging strangers
if they were going through depression or
heartbroken or felt empty or missing
someone I just want cuz that pivoted my
life and never been able to reach them
ever again so if you're listening out
there in Sydney Australia I love you you
changed my life forever and I just
wanted to be the same for them oh my
what a Magic start I'm not I didn't know
that's how it started that's how it
[Music]
[Applause]
started thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home